it has been an accident meeting
reflecting an excellent work four weeks
ago almost exactly
I had a honnor to witness together with
Commissioner Hahn the signature of the
historic name agreement with Greece we
hope that all leaders all political
parties all citizens now engage
constructively for the ratification and
the implementation not only of the
agreement signed with Greece but also
let me mention the agreement signed with
Bulgaria : all parties in the country to
engage in a constructive dialogue and
continue to deepen the current reform
momentum especially on the role of law
reform of the intelligence services and
public administration and I will be in
scope here
on the 17th of July which means next
Tuesday to launch the start of the
technical part of the screening process
together with the government
administration but they will also like
to express my on a very personal note my
congratulations for the invitation you
have received yesterday by NATO to start
accession talks this is another positive
milestone in your euro-atlantic path
which will benefit primarily the
citizens of your country and you can
already train and exercise accession
talks as Peru of Medicare karate my
Republican makedonia in a private but
never obscured but Muslim de canaima
Sandesh Kaneko go Dennis in the wooden
opposes not occur to me but which to
Sevilla Dec say oddvar Opatija
pochittona recovery who uni villa leader
at nice tag arena